[موسيقى]
انه يوم احتفل في نيودلهي بحضور مسؤولنا
في الشرطه واعضاء من الحكومه وصحافه
الوطنيه اجتمعوا للاحتفال باسترجاع تماثيل
تجسد الهه هندوسيه منها ما يعود للقرن
الحادي عشر تمت سرقتها من معابد هندوسيه
وكانت معروضه في متاحف امريكيه واستراليه
وتعمل الحكومه الهنديه على استرجاع هذه
التمثيل التي سرقت منذ عقوته
فخر كبير ان نرى ثمار جهودنا الحديثه
جعل رئيس الوزراء نارون دامودي استرجاع
هذه الاثار
احدى اولوياته في كل تحركاته خارج البلاد
منذ وصول ناردا مود الى الحكم عام 2014 تم
استرجاع 230 قطعه كهذه دون دفع اي مقابل
ماديه بمجرد استرجاعها ترسل الى المعابد
الاصليه التي سرقت منها او تعرض في هذه
القاعه التي فتحت ابوابها عام 2019
انه متحف القطع المسترجعه في قلب نيودلهي
هذا تمثال يمثل بودا وهو واقف انه من
مدينه غايه تمكنا من استرجاعه بعد مفاوضات
طويله مع الولايات المتحده
هذه المنخوتات من الرخام والبرونز التي
يعود بعضها لالاف السنين وجد جزء منها في
الخارج والبعض الاخر في الهند سرقت حديثا
او قبل الاستقلال فمنذ عقود تتعرض المعابد
الهندوسيه لعمليه نهب لصالح مهربي الاثار
نظرا للارباح الكبيره التي تدرها هذه
التجاره
المره الاولى التي استرجعت فيها الهند
قطعه مهربه كانت عام 1980 لقد طال امد هذه
الفضيحه المتمثله في تهريب التماثيل الى
الخارج ان التاريخ يسجل ان بعض ملوك الفرس
استحوذوا على جزء منها وطبعا خلال فتره
الحكم البريطاني قطع اثريه كثيره تم نقلها
الى انجلترا سلسله
هذه القطعه التي تهرب بطرق غير قانونيه
ينتهي بها المطاف في متاحف اوروبيه
وامريكيه لاطفاء اثر هذه القطع تعتمد
السلطات الهنديه على وحده خاصه تتمركز في
مدينه تشينال
عن نهايه عام 2022 تمكنت هذه الفرقه
الخاصه من استرجاع هذه المجموعه من
التماثيل بعد عشر سنوات من سرقتها هذه
الثقوب تستعمل لربط التماثيل جيدا لمنعها
من السقوط خلال بعض الاحتفالات والطقوس
الدينيه هذه خاصيه لا يمكن رؤيتها الا عند
الالهه الموجوده في المعابد
بمعابدها 47 الفا تعتبر مدينه تاميناتو
جنه المهربين خلال اربعه عقود تمكنت هذه
الوحده الخاصه من استرجاع حوالي 4,500
قطعه من بينها منخوتات ولوحات تعود بالربح
الوفير على المهربين
هم لا يترددون في دفن تماثيل وحتى اللوحات
لاخفائها يفعلون ذلك لتمكن من استخراجها
وتهريبها بعد فتره حاول السنه او سنتين
يرتفع فيها ثمن القطعه وعندما يقدرون ان
ثمنها بلغ مستويات مرتفعه
يستخرجونها ويهربونها خارج البلاد بفائده
كبيره
تتمكن الشرطه من التوصل الى بعض المهربين
بفضل المخبرين الذين يعملون معها في
الخفاءه منهم متطوعون بعضهم تمكن من تنظيم
عمله في شبكه ومنظمات تضم اعضاء من
الجاليه الهنديه في الخارج تقع على عاتقهم
مهمه التحري في المتاحف والمزادات
العالميه لاقتفاء اثر اي قطعه مهربه من
المعابد الهندوسيه
هذه الصوره اخذت داخل قاعه للعروض في
الخارج وهذه من ارشيف المعهد الفرنسي في
مدينه
الصورتان تظهران نفس التشققات لا مجال
للشك انها القطعه ذاتها
نهايه العام الماضي تمكن هؤلاء المتطوعون
من منع بيع قطعه في مزاد علني لاحدى افخم
قاعه العرض في باريس وتقدر اليونسكو ان
50,000 قطعه منهوبه من المعابد الهندوسيه
تنتشر في مختلف انحاء العالم